نحن الان امام مستشفى سلقين المركزي هنا
تنتظر عدد من العائلات اي خبر عن وصول
محتمل لجثث ذويهم من اماكن
انتشالي العالقين تحت الانقاض وفي المقابل
على رصيف المستشفى
تتجمع عدد من الجثث بانتظار ان يصل ذويهم
لتسلم الجثث و لينقلوا الجثث الى المقابر
وضع صعب جدا هنا امام المستشفى
للناس الذين يرقبون اي خبر عن ذويهم وعن
اهلهم
وهناك جثث كما حدثتنا فرق الاسعاف هناك
جثث لم يجدوا اقرباء لهم حتى يتم تسليمها
لهم
ولكن يسلموها لاقرباء من الدرجه الثانيه
او الثالثه لان
كل افراد عائله الشخص المتوفى قضوا ايضا
بعضهم وجد عثر على جثته وبعضهم الاخر لم
يعثر عليها حتى الان بانتظار استكمال
عمليات الانقاذ من المواقع التي تضررت
والمباني التي دمرت هنا في مدينه سلقين
اكثر من عشره مباني دمرت ولكنها متفرقه
منتشره في عموم البلده وما تزال حتى
اللحظه جهود فرق الدفاع المدني متواصله
لانتشال الضحايا والعالقين تحت الانقاض
صهيب الخلف الجزيره سلقين ريفوي ادلب